This week we're talking
with a self-proclaimed
normal American millennial who
grew up in America all his life,
Johnny Young.
Thank you for being here,
(cheering, applause)
Oh, thanks, Chris.
I love texts,
I love Netflix,
and chill, dawg.
Spelled D-A-W-G, the young way.
HARDWICK:
Okay, great.
Uh, well, that-that kills any
su-suspicions I might have had.
Uh, Johnny,
what do you think about
Russia's alleged interference
in our election?
Hey, chill out, man.
Russia has nothing to do
with it.
(laughs)
Bazinga!
Uh...
First of all, please don't ever
say that again, and they don't?
No, no, Chris, you've been
smoking too much
of that sticky icky, which I...
which I, as an American
millennial, also enjoy to smoke
and relax with my young friends.
(laughter)
Oh... oh, that's awful.
That's bad.
(applause)
Please... Ple...
Thank you for ceasing your dab.
According to Fortune magazine,
though,
Russian hackers are believed
to be responsible
for obtaining 19,000
private e-mails
from the Democratic party.
You're still using e-mail,
old man?
The new cool thing is Snapchat.
You can send secret messages
to every one
of your millennium friends
who have infiltrated every level
of American government,
and the messages automatically
self-destruct.
Plus, there are filters to make
you look like a bunny.
(laughs)
What a country!
-(cheering, applause)
-All right. All right.
I'm not trying to be a dick,
but you sound like
an older Eastern European man
and you look like
you run a pager store.
No.
I'm from New Jersey.
It's my hipster beard
confusing you.
I don't know.
Jack, can we pull up this guy's
credentials, please?
I'm not sure
Johnny's the real deal.
What are you doing
on your phone?
-Ah, ah, ah.
-Oh, come on.
Ah, ah, ah.
Technical difficulties.
Epic fail.
Harambe.
All right, that has
nothing to do with anything.
Why are you calling out
a deceased gorilla name
and hacking my show
at the same time?
I think this guy
might be kind of dangerous.
HARDWICK:
Uh, yeah, I don't know, I-I...
(audience exclaims)
Wait, come on,
what happened to my points?
-HARDWICK: What did you do?
-They're gone!
-What did you do?
-Hey...
they're Vladimir Putin's
points now.
HARDWICK:
No, that's it. That is it.
You know something?
You stop that clapping.
You know, you can (bleep) with
the presidential election, fine,
but don't you dare
(bleep) with the integrity
of the game portion of
@midnight, you son of a bitch.
Get out of here,
you Russian spy!
-A Russian spy, everyone.
-No.
-No, no.
-(cheering, applause)
HARDWICK:
Stop dabbing.
Don't let him dab anymore.